how's it going everybody it's worn in
Marvel's phase four is almost here just
under five months until we get the Black
Widow movie the other night we got a new
special look at Black Widow with new
scenes and of course the Internet did
its job and completely analyzed it and
we found something that leads us to
believe that perhaps Marvel is trying to
misdirect us just like they've done in
the past you know with the whole fake
infinity war and ingame scenes and the
trailers and saying that Avengers
endgame wasn't called in-game but than
it was we think that this may be
happening with Black Widow because we
found a secret there are some mysterious
objects found in Natasha's hand during
the special look and you may notice that
they look pretty familiar if you've seen
Avengers in game which I'm assuming most
of us have these are almost instantly
identifiable as Pym particles what the
avengers used in their suits to travel
back in time and avengers endgame so
there seems to be a little bit more to
Black Widow that meets the eye and I've
narrowed it down to four theories of
what could actually be happening here in
the Black Widow movie if you're new be
sure to subscribe with notifications
turned on so you can stay up to date
with the MCU and so you can enter my
giveaway for a chance to win an Xbox one
or ps4 so the first Theory goes off the
fact that these are in fact Pym
particles and as you can see they look
exactly like them the red vials that
have silver ish caps on top of them but
what does that mean why does she have
these well perhaps Black Widow has
traveled back in time and the Black
Widow that we are seeing during the
special look and during the whole entire
movie of Black Widow is actually Natasha
from Avengers endgame there's one thing
the official teaser trailer for Black
Widow and the special look for Black
Widow have in common that one special
line I'm done running from my past
Marvel is known for their classic
misdirection for MCU films and we've
been told that the Black Widow film
takes place between the events of
Captain America Civil War and Avengers
infinity war and perhaps that is true
but perhaps the Black Widow in the film
actually comes from the future that's
right this could be Black Widow from the
future from the events of Avengers
endgame going back in time before she
died to take care of her past to try and
free her so-called little sister Yelena
Bulova to try and reunite her family and
get rid of the Black Widow program once
and for all before she dies that could
be why she has so many Pym particles in
her hand because she's going back in
time to try to fix all
her wrongs before she leaves because
it's undeniable that these do really
really look like Pym particles but let's
say that they're not Pym particles and
she's not travelling back in time what
could they be
well theory number two is that these
could be a Super Soldier Serum now
you're probably thinking well Super
Soldier Serum is blue so that can't be
it
but let's not forget that the Russians
have their own type of Super Soldier
Serum modeled after the one that Steve
Rogers got this serum that the Russians
made themselves is the same one that red
guarding done and remember red Guardian
is simply a Russian Captain America
family big together again you got fat so
why does Black Widow have all of these
vials of Super Soldier Serum well it
could be that they are giving these to
the new Black Widow recruits remember
Black Widow wants to shut down the Black
Widow program and the Red Room so she
could have very well infiltrated the
program somehow and stolen these serums
this way there are no super black widows
running around that the world can't stop
and who knows perhaps she'll even inject
herself with one during the movie but
we'll have to wait till it comes out to
find out theory number three is pretty
simple this could be for her Widow bite
now normally black widows bite and
electrical shocks are blue however in
this special look we see that they are
now red she could need these vials for
her widow bite and her other
technological abilities because if it is
after Civil War she's going to be on the
run and she no longer has access to
stark technology and all of her
technology so these vials could simply
be her way of getting her black widow
bite back while she's on the run to take
down the Red Room and the last theory
theory number four is the one that we
all wish could be true she is alive
these are in fact Pym particles and she
has somehow managed to escape her fate
on Vermeer perhaps as she was falling to
her death on Vermeer she activated her
time device she goes back in time gets
more Pym particles then goes forward in
time lives her life and then when it's
finally time to move on she uses the
device once again to go back to the
exact same place where she was falling
now technically if you were following
the rules of time-travel that they
explained in Avengers endgame this is
possible if you look to the scene with
the ancient one and Bree
banner Bruce Banner says we can erase
any alternate timelines like they never
happened like the Infinity stones were
never taken and you can simply replace
an infinity stone with black widow if
she's falling to her death goes back in
time and travels throughout time lives a
full life and then returns to the exact
point in time where she was falling and
then finishes the fall to her death the
sacrifice still counts and Hawkeye still
gets the soul stone so technically
according to the logic in avengers
endgame this is possible however it's
most likely not true Scarlett Johansson
has said a couple of times that she has
hung up the Black Widow mantle this is
going to be her last movie as Natasha
Romanov but anything is possible with
Marvel they are known for their classic
misdirection even the actors do it so
any of these theories could be true but
which one do you think is most likely to
happen let me know what you think is
going to happen in the comments down
below
let me know what you think these red
vials are are they Pym particles Super
Soldier Serum let me know what you think
don't forget to give the video a like
and subscribe when notifications turned
on so you can stay up to date on
everything relating to the MCU and so
you can enter my giveaway for a chance
to win an Xbox one or ps4 and picking a
winner at five hundred and fifty
thousand subscribers don't forget to
follow on Instagram and Twitter and as
always thank you all so much for
watching
woof woof